uh i just want to make sure that
everyone got a copy of my amendment to
sb 245 i placed it on the
mr chair i have a question
um if you're a co-sponsor
we do can we make an uh
motion on that bill okay thank you yeah
the substitutes are not uh
permitted to make motions or uh
joe you were you benefited from my
mistake and the last time you were you
you were a co-sponsor of a bill and you
testified on it i shouldn't have
okay you guys basically ready to get
started
good morning everybody this is the
municipal and county government
committee
we are
here on monday april 18th
uh to uh go through executive session on
several of our bills
uh before we get started i'd ask i would
ask you all to please stand
i pledge allegiance to the divide of the
united states of america into the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
okay let's do a sound check everybody
hear me
yeah
okay
remind the committee members that
if you're called on to speak that you
turn your microphone on and when you
complete whatever you're speaking about
turn your microphone back off
okay
okay uh
the first bill we have is
uh
239 at senate bill 239 fn
and let me ask uh
rich representative lacellus do you have
a motion you'd like to make yes mr
chairman i move uh ought to pass
on
239.
okay thank you
uh discussion among the committee
members
yes oh second i'm sorry
representative power seconds that motion
and what do we have for discussion
on uh
on 239
yes representative gallagher um
so
this one seems like a
a pretty
unobjectionable
minor change so
um
yeah i think it makes sense and that we
should pass it
okay
anybody else
seeing none
oops
oh
i'm sorry representative tripp uh thank
you mr chair uh this is
one of those bills where uh
we have a law that we have no uh
penalty for
either ignoring it or disobeying it i
guess ignoring and dissipating is
probably pretty close to the same thing
but uh
i i think that it's a it's an
improvement in the law and that uh it
adds some a penalty to the
failure to
uh for the municipal
uh
body to uh not do an audit so uh
uh i'm in favor of the bill too thank
you thank you any other comments
please okay uh for those of you who are
subbing in we're gonna do our um voting
okay so uh mr clerk please call the roll
on uh on
otp motion for 239.
thank you mr chairman uh vice chairman
pam monty
yes collect votes yes
representative tripp
representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas
yes
represent
representative melvin
yes
representative
yes representative power yes
representative davis
yes
representative jack yes
representative gilman
yes
uh representative perez
representative megapootie
yes
representative fan
representative clee yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative wrong yes and chairman
dolan yes
that was 239 consent
okay
chairman yes do we want to put that on
consent i i don't know if we can do that
i don't know i'll check on that
but it also has fn i'm sorry fn well
it's got an fn also but uh
but but if it didn't i still wouldn't i
still don't know
but let me uh before we go
uh very deep into this let me uh i'm
going to recess the
so we stand in recess right now if
anybody needs to
use the
facilities would you need a good time
so way to go ivy you caused this to uh
delay
good
um
all right
okay uh we're back in session we're
uh at senate bill 239 fn
the the question that was outstanding
was uh
we normally deal with house bills and
this is these are senate bills today and
the question was putting
bills like this on the consent calendar
now the answer is yes and no
yes we can put senate bills on
consent calendar but this particular
bill we can't because it has an n next
to it and it means it has to go to
finance first to be reviewed
so uh
so uh we don't need a motion to put it
on consent
all right next bill is uh senate bill
235.
uh chairman
i'm sorry 245. this representative tripp
do you have a motion mr mr chairman
if i couldn't yes i'd like to move an
amendment
235 yes 45 45 sorry 245 yes
it's submitted by representative
gallaher and it's a
technical
correction
it
under the duties
it changes the
wording trash removal to waste removal
representative gallagher do you have
copies of that
uh yeah i placed them by the on the
table
with where the name tags go so everyone
okay good it's circulating uh anybody
it's just a trash to waste yes that's
all the only change yes
all right i'll take a motion uh
i'm sorry the people who who uh wrote
the answer bill the uh amendment
representative gallagher i'm going to
ask you a minute to make make that
motion to accept the amendment
i believe representative guthrie just
made it so um i'll i'd like to second
uh and if i may speak to
the motivation
yes you can stick to your motion
um so
yeah the
reason for changing trash to waste is
pretty simple i just want to make sure
that compost and recycling are covered
as well as
regular trash so i thought that waste
was the broader term that
would
include all of those
so that's it thank you any other
comments on the on the amendment
that's been brought to you
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you for letting
me make a comment similarly i second my
colleague
representative gallagher
um
it just changes
not just focused on one aspect of the
waist so this just
and it's a shock study too so it looks
at all and so this encompasses that's
why i back that
any other comments on the
amendment yes
mr chair may i ask um representative
guthrie just to restate the number of
the amendment
sure
yes i'd be glad to i'm awful sorry uh
it's uh
2022-1452h
and stated 10
5.
representative guthrie
thank you hit that hit that button thank
you
uh any other questions or comments on
the amendment
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call a
vice-chairman pmrt
yes clerk votes yes
representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas yes
uh representation yes
representative melvin yes representative
here yes
representative power yes
representative davis yes
representative jack yes
representative gilman
yes representative perez
okay
oh thank you
uh
representative mangapudi
yes
representative vance yes representative
clee
yes
representative gallagher
representative brung yes
chairman dolan yes
okay at this point we're going to look
to representative
tripp to make a motion with the chair
yes i would like to make octopuses
amended
mr chair yes i uh move itl
second
motion has been made and seconded
may i speak to my motion yes
this is a interesting bill in that uh
it's uh
it's between
municipalities
and condo owners
and
i i don't really see how this is a
a issue that the state should be dealing
with
uh if there's a if there's a problem
between
the
municipality and uh people living there
then it should be dealt with
within the municipality and not
something that uh should be studied to
determine
you know how we could better
uh resolve these issues
you know if it's if it's an issue that
was created locally then it should be
solved locally and this is why i made my
itl motion
thank you any further discussion on
uh the motion hasn't met as amended mr
chair yes
i would like to
disagree with the itl this is yes it's a
local issue
but there's no
[Music]
property tax is not just local it also
is a state
and
since
this is a study
to look at there are some
uh in
consistencies inconsistencies across
so to look at there's it's not an
enabling legislation it's not changing
anything
and we have dealt with uh other issues
where waste management and the state is
looking at and
you know we have discussed we have other
bills that has looked at this and it's
an issue and it's uh not just the
statewide it is the trash removal
and uh the municipal waste
disposal and uh how we deal with it is
an issue that was faced with every
municipality every state and nationwide
and
if we just look at the other say and say
this is not our problem
i disagree with that and so i would not
be supporting itl
thank you yes representative please
thank you um mr chairman and uh
committee members
when i wasn't here when the when the
public hearing happened but the the more
i've talked to people in the
understanding i have i believe that
between the municipalities and um the
condo associations and people in in
general there seems to be some kind of
confusion as to the fees and where they
go and so on and um i think that's what
could help warrant a study
while i agree with my uh my colleague
that um sometimes the state and
municipalities kind of conflict and we
need to let the municipalities make the
decision i think this study would just
kind of help with some recommendations
and might help guide the municipalities
a little bit better so um that's why i
was for it so thank you thank you any
other discussion
yes representative guthrie yeah thank
you mr chairman i understand that
there's a lot of
committees and commissions and
i just it's just another one but i think
it's the one that's worthwhile as
co-sponsor of the uh the bill i i feel
it is
uh something we
the condominium and renters need uh help
in uh uh taking a look at this problem
so i will vote against the itl
okay uh any other comments
yes
just a question of chair i didn't hear a
second do we have a second on this bill
thanks uh representative melvin all
right
yes representative perez
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak up i agree that we have a lot of
study committees going on um in the
environmental and agricultural committee
but this is
one that i i believe this is going to
work this is going to help us to
continue this study that we're really
doing with
the
other committees so i believe that uh
that the itl i will not support because
thank you
any further discussion
on the on this uh
okay so uh
what we're going to be voting on is
the motion to itl as amended
senate bill 235 245.
vice chairman pmrt
collect votes yes representative tripp
yes
representative los alas
obviously
yes representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative stavis
no
representative jack no representative
gilman
no
representative perez
representative mega poody
no
representative fan no
representative klee no
representative gallagher
no
chairman dolan no
uh motion i'm sorry uh let me correct
that yes my vote is yes okay uh
yes
i make a motion to pass as amended
is there a second
representative
man
any discussion on the motion
yes uh representative
thank you mr chair
no i would just say that
and i wasn't here when you folks debated
this bill but it looks to me as though
it
just wants to insert the state into an
agreement that a developer makes in on
behalf of
condominium owners and it seems to me
that
that should stay
a
an agreement between
the renters or owners and the developers
slash
property managers who was ever managing
that
and
i don't think the state should be
involved in this so i will vote
against the ought to pass motion
thank you representatives davis
um
yes i would um agree with my colleague
uh where not for the fact that trash
pickup fees are tacked onto state
property tax bills local and state
property tax bills and so it very much
is a state matter in my view and so i
will be voting to
support the ought to pass as amended i
think there's a lot of confusion around
private communities whether they be
homeowners associations condominium
associations or other types of
developments
as to who pays for what but everyone
regardless of who pays for what pays
any other discussion yes representative
manchapudi thank you mr chair
considering that we are in a
housing crisis um
across the state and every municipality
every community is trying to create
a housing opportunity for people to live
work and
raise the family
this will help because there is a rush
to create a lot of much needed housing
and if we have you know this is more
recent and the inconsistency yes
oh set your point of order does the bill
has to do with condominiums and their
i am coming to it condominiums and their
uh
fees and homeowner associations
not uh additional housing to be built
no i am coming to it i've already been
built
okay uh
the amendment may continue yeah thank
you mr chair i'm coming to it because it
is between the developer and the zoning
of each community and that is where the
inconsistencies are
and the new constructions are paying the
taxes but not having the
trash pick up that is the clarification
that's needed so that's why i think this
is very needed
much needed in time
and i would be supporting
oh you already
uh we already went to you yes sir
representative wrong
thank you mr chair
i just want to remind the committee this
is just to set up a committee
to look at this
i found the testimony of the gentleman
the retired the man that was retired
that moved into a condominium
community very compelling
he's denied municipal services that he's
paying for
um that are that are given to other
condominium owners and other residents
of his community i think that at least
looking at this examining it see how how
widespread it is i think is
is doing these uh granite staters a
service i think we owe it to at least
have it looked at thank you
thank you representative any other
conversation yes representative davis
sorry mr chair i realized i did have a
comment
um
in my community in lebanon we have
recently approved or in the process of
approving approximately
2500 new units of housing
state law is silent
on
what the arrangements are going to be to
remove trash from 2000 new units of
housing that's a lot of trash that's a
i think it would be beneficial for
everyone in the state certainly would be
beneficial for my constituents to have a
study committee that looks at this issue
because it's not just who pays issue
it's a sanitation and a
thank you uh
representative tripp
thank you mr
chair uh
i'm still a little dumbfounded in that
the the need for this
study committee
because if all that is permitted to
study
is
agreements between developers and
municipalities on municipal trash
removal fees
it seems like
we're using a
nuclear weapon to destroy
you know an ant hill
uh
once again
this is something that
uh
condominiums
owners
or condominium associations are
a rather unique animal in in the state
of new hampshire
uh
if if they were to have an agreement
within with the municipality
uh on
how trash pickup is going to be
performed
i would think that uh once again if if
if it was done
relatively early in the formation of the
the condo association
you know to
keep costs down
uh
or whatever if there was a reason for it
then
if later on people find out that no
we're not getting a service but we're
paying for it this is something that
once again the municipal association the
condo association and municipality
should revisit the agreement you know
i i find it amazing that the state is
getting
involved in something as miniscule as
this uh
where the trash goes as some of the
other members of the committee you know
mentioned this is an issue
that's
that's not going to be discussed in this
committee because it's limited to
uh agreements between the condo
associations and the uh
municipalities
if someone wants to amend
the bill to give it a little more reach
and range
then i would probably support it but
right now the
the study committee it's limited
by
the the reason it's
established
to talk about municipal trash removal
you know
it's
once again it's it's
a i i don't believe there's any merit to
the bill thank you
yes uh representative davis
gilman i'm gilmar i'm sorry
uh thank you mr chair i i understand uh
the reluctance and i keep hearing the
state shouldn't get involved but this is
not getting involved this is a committee
to study
not just um
what happens between a municipality and
a
condo or homeowners association but it
says examine
issues and issues are where does the
trash go how does the town pay for it
how do the condominium owners pay for it
every town has some form perhaps of a
different
agreement and i think the study
committee would establish
again because we have landfill
[Music]
problems i mean citing landfills are
trying to get close them down that
affects what the towns do
with their costs and what the taxpayers
pay and i understand condominium payers
are paying for something they don't get
but that's a that's a choice that the
and this i think the committee
needs to look at because we have laws
regarding condominium associations this
is one of the things that we might want
to look at and recommend adding
verbiage about that into condominium
association agreements
so as a study committee you know it's
not enabling it's just going to come up
with recommendations
thank you mr chair thank you any further
yes representative power
thank you mr chair um it's clear that
these
agreements between the developers and
the municipalities were made at the
local level therefore if there are any
um
if there's any unhappiness or
the people in the hoa do not
like the agreement
at this point in time then in my mind
this should be
dealt with at the local level the state
did not get involved in these agreements
it's my understanding and therefore they
the state should not
be
be studying this it's a local issue
it it is derived at the local level and
therefore should be
okay in further discussion on the bill
yes
representative
thank you mr chair
so
i heard um
one of the representatives say that
we're not getting involved in this it's
just a study committee well if we're not
getting involved and why study it
i concur that this is a local agreement
and
it should be something dealt with at the
local level with the governing board of
whatever that town of municipality is
um in regard to landfills uh closing
that's
that is a fact that they're closing in
many places but if you're gonna if
you're going to study it then you should
study the whole thing
that affects
not just
condominium
owners and renters but it affects
everybody potentially at the local level
but again the governing boards of these
municipalities ultimately decide
who they're going to contract with the
dude trash pick up some municipalities
don't even have that it's up to the end
of it
individual property owner to take care
of that on a private contract so i just
think we're getting involved in
something that um we shouldn't be
getting involved in
thank you representative tripp
thank you mr chair
it uh
it seems that we're getting a little
scope creep here
agreements between municipalities and uh
condo associations and and now i find
that we're gonna be talking about
landfills and uh how to deal with trash
uh are we going to be talking about
the type of vehicles that are used to
remove
the the trash
is is this a effort to
get electric vehicles involved you know
what
i believe
the bill is for
is
being grown
to where
you know it yes it does become a state
issue if you if you
investigate all these issues but once
again
the
the bill is to investigate
or study
uh
in my mind a single issue
in
is it portsmouth i believe it's
sportsman where
they they somehow made an agreement
early on in the in the uh development of
the condo association
uh
to
not
get uh trash pick up
you know
this is this is the old uh
making a mountain out of a mohil issue
and this is why i don't agree with the
otp motion thank you representative
manchipuri thank you mr chair i want to
bring everybody's attention back to what
the bill is committee to establish there
is an established committee to study
agreements between developers and
municipalities on municipal trash
removal fee paid by the condominium
owners and renters
period
so the amendment just changes the trash
removal to solid waste which encompasses
nobody's talking about the reason we are
using the word landfill or the
inconsistency because the
inconsistencies were brought from one
community and i am one of the
co-sponsors because i got some uh
community my constituency
to
i'm sorry please continue
thank you uh
there are inconsistency in my own
community that the constituents brought
to my attention and i would just not
sponsor something which i didn't think
it existed in my community and so it is
to study the inconsistency and solid
waste and trash is a big issue in every
community and we need to have some
consistent
answers and it's a very short
focused
and that's why i urge my colleagues to
support it
thank you mister thank you
representatives
okay we're going to take a vote on
senate bill
to whether or not we want to
itl this bill i'm sorry otp this bill as
amended
mr clerk take the role
thank you mr chairman uh vice chairman
piamanti no
look votes no
representative tripp
no
representative guthrie
representative los alas no
uh representative
no
representative melvin no
representative here
no
representative power no
representative davis
yes
representative jack yes
representative gilman yes
representative perez
yes
probably mega pooty
representative fan yes representative
clee
yes
representative ryan yes
and chairman dolan no
democratic leader
to a sign
committee report i will do the majority
report mr chair
all right
okay we're going to move on now to
senate bill 246
and 246 is relative to qualified private
communities
representative ayer do you have a motion
representative power yes i'd like to
second that
to itl
is there any discussion
yes representatives davis
um thank you mr chair i
cannot agree with an itl on this bill
because as in a previous bill
we have a
present and growing issue in our state
with so-called private qualified private
communities whether they be condominium
associations garden apartment
developments
homeowners associations or the like
where
developers make agreements with local
planning boards that have
vast implications
for the future residents or owners of
those
it is sometimes said let the buyer
beware you know what you're getting into
when you buy into one of these
communities but sometimes you don't
and more often than not
that sometimes is
there are
55 pages of legal
arguments in the homeowners association
documents that no reasonable person
could understand
and so they get saddled with costs that
they do not expect to pay
costs that their neighbors who live on
public streets do not pay because no
developer was involved and no agreement
was made
i think that there was a basic issue of
fairness here
the once
and if the argument is made well then
just go back to the planning board and
undo it that can't be done
under current statute that can't be done
in terms of homeowners associations our
state doesn't even have any law
that provides guidelines to homeowners
associations only condominiums so we
have a plethora of growing types of
housing that's considered private
housing on private roads
where
unsuspecting citizens are getting roped
into
deals that they will not be able to
afford
because the municipalities will not pay
for essential services such as road
repair and things like that and i think
that this is a
major issue that is only going to become
more major
as more housing units get developed
and i think it deserves a study
committee thank you
any further discussion yes
representative manjuputi thank you mr
chair i couldn't uh second or
amplify my colleague who made a comment
just now this is i was surprised at how
many people
testified in support and how many miles
of private roads are in
one for example just laconia has over 30
communities
that have private roads so
if they're coming for a clarification
and this is you know instead of itling
we could
make another motion to show we have
heard that isn't that our role as us
look at what issues we have in different
communities i'm not saying we have to
make
rules for every community overarching
but at least if the concerns are brought
isn't that our duty as state
legislators to look at and study it and
not show uh
put it
aside as itl thank you mr klee
thank you mr chairman and thank you
committee members for hearing me out um
again i i was not here for the the
public hearing but i i did do some
homework as well as listen to that and
and i spoke to um
our community development people in in
nashua and one of the things that i'm
seeing more and more um is that we're
getting these these community type of
builds in our municipalities because
space is smaller and smaller and when we
we have these type of condominiums and
so on these roads do become
private
when i first moved to new hampshire i
lived in a condominium type of thing and
one of the things was that it wasn't
that old of a condominium and soon the
roads started kind of breaking down and
we actually had sinkholes we had this
and suddenly there were these
monumentous kind of assessments that
were put on all of the owners
um we could pay them over five years but
if we sold the place we were still
responsible for it and so on it really
became a burden
and the sad thing was it also happened
just as the market crashed so the values
of our homes went down and suddenly we
had this if there had been some type of
an escrow
where money was put to place that could
have taken care of that that would have
been less of a burden and we might not
have had as many people running away
from their their homes i think a study
is a good thing and i'm gonna preface
this with this is the second time i'm
now here voting for a study and i don't
usually like too many studies because i
think they go nowhere
but i think this might be one of those
that
might be helpful to kind of give some
ideas i don't think it's necessarily
going to come out and say
you have to do this you have to do that
but it might find some polls some ways
of
working these contracts a little bit
better um and so on and you know as an
alderman i hate putting any burden on
the municipality but i do think that um
having some type of um
of study or or even you know if we could
move this past itl and get to a study
and i apologize for kind of mixing
things up here um i i think might be a
good idea so for that reason i cannot
vote for an ital on this so thank you
representative tripp
thank you mr chair
uh
since we're talking about reasonable
persons
uh
it's interesting that uh
a reasonable person
wouldn't be
somewhat skeptical about the lower cost
of a condominium
a
independent house
if
if i was to
uh
be looking at the cost of
building a buying a residence and i was
to find out that oh a condominium it's
you know forty thousand dollars cheaper
than buying a house on uh
uh
uh in in the town
i would be wondering
why
it's so much cheaper
and
you know yes the condominium agreements
are rather lengthy uh
55 pages is probably skimpy you know but
uh
the reason they're long is because the
law
the current law
uh
it doesn't mandate that the uh uh
agreements be so long but uh you know
from a legal perspective the developers
know that uh
they have to disclose uh
one of the things that they're not good
at disclosing is future costs and
conditions and i agree that this might
be a solution
to
something like this because
uh
it
it would let the people know that
if you're having to establish an escrow
account like this bill does
that there's a reason the reason is the
roads are not built to uh
proper standards and that you're going
to have to be
uh
paying money
to to uh
uh fix them
and and yes you will be getting you know
large
homeowners or condo assessments because
you know
you're reaping the harvest of what
you've sown
you know if if you
don't understand that
discounted property
as it's it's risk
you know then
you're going to end up like this
this
um
this is a solution
i think it's a band-aid more than a uh
than a fix
because
uh
you you're requiring the developer to
establish an escrow account and guess
what that's going to do it's going to
raise the cost of the
of the condos
and the other thing is
years down the road it's going to happen
again now this is not a solution it's a
band-aid you know if people
don't understand what they're getting
into
it's too bad and my in my opinion
and this is why i support the itil
thank you representative gallagher
so
i'd just like to um clarify a bit with
people talking about
studying where that's coming from so the
bill itself is not a study committee the
bill actually does stuff
it
defines
uh qualified private communities
and
put some regulations on them
so
where this where the studying is coming
from is if
the itl motion fails
the studying would come from a motion to
interim study this bill it wouldn't it
wouldn't be from
trying to pass it
so i
i think we agree
that this bill needs some work we're
just differing on how exactly we want to
do that work
davis
so i'm gonna take that band-aid i really
need that band-aid
because
my homeowners association levied four
special assessments last year
because the road that our homes are
built on and by the way our homes are
way more expensive
than many single-family homes elsewhere
in our community so that so the the
fiction the condominiums or homes on
private roads are
de facto less expensive than other homes
is a fiction
um
the city will not repair our
roads in order for the city to repair
our roads it would have to go through a
lengthy municipal process legal process
to accept the roads as public roads
which it will not do because it would
cost the city money to do that this is
an issue that is a statewide issue that
needs to be studied and the and the
answer that
if some people don't know what they're
getting into that's too bad
well you could say that about a lot of
things and it would kind of be a little
sketchy i think
so just to put it right out there it is
a fiction
that condominiums and homes and
homeowners associations are somehow less
expensive
and therefore you have to you should
expect to spend more on their upkeep
that's not true
anywhere in our state
and number two
i
heartily agree with my colleague that
this bill is not a study bill this is a
bill that proposes legislation
i will support the itl on this bill if
we can make a subsequent
okay uh
a private road
is nothing more than a shared driveway
the same things
in a condo association that you pay for
to maintain your parking lot
is the same as maintaining that road
when you buy a home or a condo on a
private road
all that road is is shared by everybody
on that road
everybody pays in to plow it
everybody pays in to maintain it
and to have the state step in
basically a developer will just build a
road
that's a town road
then you'll get it plowed but you'll pay
a lot more money for your house you'll
pay a lot more money for your taxes
if your house was expensive then that
was what the market called for
uh i know where i live
ninety percent of the roads are private
roads
they pay less in taxes
than
than we do that live on town roads
so basically
you know to have a contractor
put aside
like i heard a number fifty thousand
dollars
you know say you fix that road
and five years from now you've got to
fix it again does he have to come back
and give you another 50 000
i think that's the question i have
and that's why i think we should i tell
it
thank you representative representative
clay
thank you for allowing me a second bite
at this apple i don't disagree with my
my colleagues
relative to the fact that
this bill as written does need some work
but i think it also has as as what uh
like my colleague
there
had pointed out it does have some merits
and it does have some place to go
those in condo associations
we
do have lengthy and i no longer live in
one of those but there there are lengthy
roads when they purchase these these
places they don't think oh these are our
private roads or these or that um i
still think that they're reasonably
minded people
but i don't think that they quite grasp
that whole concept of it and as i
pointed out having
having this this sudden
one right after another and and those
aren't the only things that you that you
get assessments on without without
realizing it you have roofs you have
decks you have all these type of things
and the reason why in some cases that
they are cheaper is because you don't
necessarily own the land the group
itself the association owns and lands
and that's what your fees are for and
your fees are for any amenities that you
have i think even reasonable people
don't realize that their roads
are not quite the same built wise as
town roads are
they they don't have as quite a life as
the town roads have and
while i i agree you know fifty thousand
dollars or whatever the number is that
they're going to put in there that needs
to be looked at and it needs to be who's
going to be have ownership of that
escrow account and does it just get
established by the
developer and then the association has
to continue with one and and so on i
just think it's a good idea to look into
this and as was pointed out this is not
an interim study bill this isn't a a
pass or fail bill but i think um
if we move past the itl and we could get
to an interim study that would be
better serving the people so thank you
representative wrong
thank you mr chair and i want to agree
with my colleague from nashua
i'm not supportive of the itl i support
interim study and it's for a reason that
hasn't been brought up today but it was
brought up in the public hearing and
that's the fact that these public roads
impact
a lot more people than the people that
are using them
because private roads not being built to
any type of state or local standard
are one of the biggest reasons that we
are seeing pollution in watersheds
the uncontrolled runoff from public road
from private roads which we don't really
see as much with with public roads
affects everybody that lives in a
watershed and what we've been seeing the
last few years in new hampshire and it's
it's we're going to see it more this
year is the growth of cyanobacteria
blooms
i'm involved with a watershed management
study in moultonborough and what we're
seeing is that a lot of private roads
that are built in a watershed have
uncontrolled runoff and so the damage of
these private roads goes far beyond the
multiple communities that are suffering
from
contamination in their waterways in
particular their lakes thank you
yes
thank you this is actually a procedural
question
if we wish to get to interim study we
have to defeat
the itl motion is that correct
yes representative
thank you mr chair
we're hearing that this
this many problems with the bill
and so if we itl the bill saying how
it's the second year of the uh term
somebody can bring back up hopefully a
better bill if this is what you want to
do
but
what concerns me is that
we're talking about
these private communities
the word private with private roads
people have moved into these
with an agreement
knowing
the at least they should certainly know
if they've read their agreement that
it's a private road to private uh
community
now if you don't like the deal you want
to
have the state intervene and change the
deal for you it's it's totally
inappropriate if this is comes down to a
zoning issue then again that's done at
the local level if
you don't like the way it was zoned then
you work through your local zoning
boards i support the itale and i hope we
move on to that uh call them a
there is a fire code that says how wide
the road has to be
the road has to be 30 feet wide so fire
trucks can pass each other on that road
so there is standards on these roads in
the beginning
and the planning board makes those
decisions with the developer but he does
have to follow those codes
representative tripp
thank you mr chair uh
i've heard several times that uh there's
a
a wastewater issue
uh
with the private roads
and i i find this
to be once again a
a state problem and that
i would believe that
when
a development even the development that
has private roads
it has to go before the planning board
and i believe the planning board you
know at least when i was on the planning
board one of the the things that we
looked at was
what are they going to do with the
wastewater that runs off the roofs that
runs off the roads that runs off of any
other impervious
uh surface
uh irene in fact as i remember
you know uh
when the developer couldn't answer that
question that we
killed the development
you know so
this is interesting that this is brought
up as a problem but this is once again a
local problem that the planning board
should deal with you know if they're not
doing it then they should you should
have a better planning board not a law
that
mandates
well they actually already have a law
that mandates that wastewater has to be
i just don't understand
why uh
you know
this this is all of a sudden an issue
that uh thank you
thank you representative guthrie yes
just a comment i think one of the
unintended consequences of
going down this road is first that the
developer would pass on his costs
to the buyers
uh in the first place and then in the
second place we have a real serious
housing problem in new hampshire nobody
denies that
and i think that this
would
increase because it would increase the
cost to the developer it might slow down
our attempts
and the governor's attempts particularly
i think we've all read recently the
governor's
desire to use state i mean in federal
funds in order to support the uh
developer side of the
uh
equation for solving the passing problem
so i i agree with the itl
i think we ought to be
doing anything everything we can to help
our developers
uh and on the building side to decrease
the cost of housing and to
increase the
availability of housing and i think the
unintended consequences of this bill is
it would have an impact on that
so i would be voting in favor of itl
thank you representative uh further
discussion
yes representative perez thank you i i
agree with my colleague
that yes we have a housing crisis but we
do have a water contamination crisis as
well
and i believe
we need to protect both of them and and
this is something that that you know is
critical and uh for that reason i will
not support the itl motion
thank you
just to uh remind everybody this has
been a rather lengthy discussion
we are
considering senate bill 246
there's an open motion to itl
and we will soon take a vote on it so i
just want to make sure everybody knows
what bill we're working on and where we
are
any further discussion before we
seeing none
i asked the clerk to take the role
please
okay isp 246. uh right champion monty
yes
collect votes yes representative tripp
representative guthrie
representation yes
representative melvin yes representative
yeah
representative power yes
representative stavis
no representative jack no
representative gilman no
representative perez
no
reps of mega pooty
representative van no
representative clee no
representative gallagher
no
representative ryan no
chairman dolan yes
thank you mr clerk
and we are
finished with that senate bill we're
going to move on to senate bill
and i'll ask representative tripp if he
has a motion he'd like to make
thank you mr chair
uh
i move uh interim study
okay before we move any further with the
the motioning
i want to recognize an amendment that
was submitted by representative umberger
so i'd like to i'd like to make sure
that you all have a copy of that
amendment do we have to take back the
second one
would you withdraw your second on the
let me first
he made the motion i think no
richard i'm sorry
we're going to go backwards here and
consider the amendment first so can i
get you to restore your amendment
representative i'll draw my motion all
right thank you
okay we're considering now amendment
to senate bill 249 it's amendment number
submitted by representative umberger 1 3
mr chair i'll move otp on the amendment
okay is there a second
i'll second that okay
you get that
okay the motion's been made and seconded
yes representative gallagher so
just to clarify what the amendment does
this is just basically
and
all um
the only new part is the part from line
17 to 18
the exemption for the kearsarge planning
who are you asking that
um asking
or um
who made the motion to uh yeah so um rip
ripless i guess is that how you
understand it
that's correct okay
on the amendment
seeing nano has to collect parole on the
amendment
okay uh vice chairman pia monty yes
collect votes yes representative tripp
yes
guthrie
los alas yes
our situation yes
representative
melvin
yes
representative yes
representative power yes
representative stavis yes
representative jack yes
representative gilman yes
representative perez
yes
represent mega pooty yes representative
vann
yes representative clee
yes representative gallagher
yes
uh motion passes thank you mister
one
18 to 1.
all right now we're faced with voting on
the
uh
the bill
as amended and a turn back to
representative tripp do you have a
motion
i still have an interim study motion
okay
and it's been second
represented
motion's been made and seconded i'll ask
now for discussion any discussion your
representative gallagher
um so i remember
hearing discussion that there might
possibly be a second amendment
drafted to this bill to address things
such as
cops conditional use
um i forgot what the ps4
permits and um
and then also residency requirements um
did that turn out not to get drafted
after all
or um
does um
or
i i believe representative maggiore was
going to um
have that drafted but since he's not
here i guess it looks like
representatives davis can answer
representatives davis
i'll try
there is no amendment that i know of
there was discussion about a potential
amendment but nothing has been drafted
by ols and nothing has been distributed
to the committee
thank you representative tripp
thank you mr chair
uh
you
might have noticed i didn't make an itl
motion that's because
uh i think this bill has merit
uh but i don't think it's ready for
prime time
uh
the uh
the idea of sprinkling
uh
b and b's or and and whatever
is uh in in residential
uh residentially zoned areas in in towns
not a good idea in my mind because uh
you have people that
are have have established homes
and and have certain expectations of of
uh
how the uh
area is going to be
uh
it's not going to be uh
noisy with people partying
there's not going to be you know an
overload of cars due to the the the
rentals the short-term rentals uh
it's something that uh
i think would be an annoyance to me if
if if there was uh i think
one of the
comments in the uh
testimony was that uh
there was a bus showed up from harvard
with 30 people in a six bedroom house
and uh
i i doubt that that would
uh meet the requirements of the fire
code
i don't know how many cars were there
but i doubt that would meet the parking
ordinance
there's just a lot of things that need
to be considered
in the implementation of short-term
rentals in uh
the towns here in
new hampshire
i understand that it's a uh
economically it's it's quite a boost
to have short-term rentals because it
brings people into the towns
you know
they spend their money and then they go
home
so
i think
what needs to be done is spend a little
time
uh
looking at
some of the issues that were brought up
in the uh
the testimony
so uh and that's why i uh
support
the interim study motion
thank you representative clay
uh thank you mr chairman and my
colleagues
um
i i truly find so many holes in this one
um that it it disturbs me um i agree we
the the monies that would be brought in
from people spending and then leaving
um is is incredible and i'm sure that
there's some towns in some cities that
even would like that but
i'm going to take from what a previous
um one of my colleagues here said at the
at the last um
comment about whether or not like an
interim study would have been
appropriate
this is the second year and this does
have a lot of issues with it and to put
an interim study together to try to fix
all that's wrong with this
um i think is is a big ask and as this
is the the last year of this um
this session so to speak perhaps it
would be best for someone who um is
truly interested in this to bring it
forward with maybe some of those fixes
rather than the state and this body
having to try to put those those fixes
through for them
i do feel that it once again would be
incumbent upon the um
the municipalities putting a you will do
this type of thing and that always
bothers me when we're mandating our our
towns and our in our cities to do
something like this so for this reason
um i cannot
i cannot support an interim study and i
would like to see that go down and so we
could bring in itl thank you
thank you representative stavis
thank you mr chair
uh and i agree with all of my colleagues
for three major reasons
and the first maybe is who picks up the
trash
[Laughter]
yeah thank you who picks up the waste
and the runoff
so in our last conversation we we took a
lot of time debating about local control
and how the state should not meddle in
local affairs and this bill is nothing
but a big meddling in local affairs it's
telling towns and cities that they can't
do something even if it's in the best
interest of that town or city to do
something and that is not something that
we do here in new hampshire
and number three i would just like to
call everyone's attention to an incident
that took place yesterday
last night i believe
in pittsburgh and it's true pittsburgh
is not new hampshire although we do have
a pittsburgh in new hampshire
where two people were
shot to death
several people were wounded
in an airbnb that was set up for
i don't know three or four people and
there were
roughly 200 people at a party there
and the response by airbnb after the
after the fact
was they're going to ban this host from
their platform forever
well that's not going to bring those two
dead people back
and i say let's look at this further
let's look at the holes in the bill that
my colleague raised and let's think
about what local towns and cities should
be able to do to protect their citizens
thank you representative wrong
thank you mr chair
um
first off i agree with my colleague from
lebanon that and we've had a lot of
discussion today about the
role of municipalities and that they
should have some say in their
communities and what they approve or
disapprove so
um i i'm against this bill because i i
believe it infringes on
the decisions that municipalities should
have for local control
as far as the interim study goes
i'm not going to support interim study
because i'll only vote for interim study
if i want to give up some of my summer
to serve on that committee and i'm not
willing to for this bill thank you
any further discussion
yes representative
thank you mr chair
i agree with the many of the comments my
colleagues have made
and if
anything my email looked like
my inbox was filled with
opposition to this bill
and you know at a point where i couldn't
get any more emails it was
until i cleared all the emails
so if there's such a concern in terms of
the short-term rental and taking away
local control and keeping the public
safety
in mind i want to make sure
my community and my constituents are
safe and my municipalities able to
support that
and at the same time support the tourism
and economic development it goes hand in
hand so
from that i cannot
support
the
you know this needs to be itled
and i cannot support the income starting
is it further discussion yes
representative gallagher
so
i'd like to echo comments that previous
colleagues have made
about the problems with this bill um
so and i i support the motion to put it
to
interim study because i do think that
passing some sort of legislation about
airbnbs or vrbos or whatever other
short-term rental platforms there are
are worthwhile um a lot of people i know
use them i used one myself when going
out to visit my brother in oregon last
fall
um
but yeah there are things that need to
be worked on like the uh
the conditional use permits and the
residency requirements and one other
issue
i remembered that might be worth it
worth looking at is um
whether there's
racial profiling
going on if we want to give
municipalities any
tools to prevent racial profiling by
airbnb hosts for um
on their guests
so i think those are all things that
could be looked at in an interim study
committee and that's why i support this
question
representative power
thank you mr chair
i support the premise of this bill it's
it's a matter of private property
ownership in in their rights
and yet at the same time there needs to
be a framework um
in which
short-term rentals can exist and
function within a community so it's a
balancing act
representative gilman
thank you mr chair uh my
position on this or question on this is
why is this one use
a local issue all of our other zoning
uses are local
decisions
and this bill
doesn't do that and i think an interim
study
there's too much in this bill that needs
to have a serious look to get an interim
study by november
so i can't support either the inter
otp
thank you further discussion yes
representative guthrie yes if i could mr
chairman
as a local official i i have to i would
have to be against this bill
as submitted
however i have no uh problem
if the
committee votes to interim study i would
vote yes
on that just to have an opportunity
maybe to assist
our local communities in this area but
once if the bill comes back with any
prohibiting any planning or any zoning
audience i could not
uh vote for that in the future but i
think
if the committee feels that they
there is some merit in
coming up with some assistance to the
local community i will i will and would
vote for interim study
thank you
further discussion
seeing none uh let me summarize where
we're at at this point
we're voting on senate bill 249
which is under a a
motion
to
to go to interim study
so we're going to do something that's
rarely done we're going to vote on
interim study as amended
everybody understand that oh yeah yeah
you know we don't see that very often
okay
so take the role please
okay uh
um
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp yes
represent guthrie
representative los alas yes
officer trojan
yes
officer melvin yes
representative here yes representative
powell yes
davis
yes representative jack yes
representative gilman
yes
representative perez yes
trump senator fan
yes
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
yes
representative wrong no
chairman dolan yes
will that go on the consent calendar
yeah
remember that any single representative
can pull bills off of consent
up until the uh
the meeting
all right we're going to move now on to
which is relative to the advisory board
resident representative power do you
have a motion
thank you mr chair i'd like to move
ought to pass on senate bill 251 is
there a second second
motion has been made in seconds
representative power made the motion and
representative melvin
all right is there a discussion on the
motion
yes representative powell thank you mr
chair that this bill um makes a
nominal change
to uh current statute in the composition
of the advisory board and it specifies
that this board shall have at least one
member
that is an owner or occupant occupant
of the property within the development
district so i support this
to pass motion any further discussion
yes representative guthrie i just like
to say i it's a pleasure to vote in
favor of what to pass and support uh
the
main sponsor of this bill thank you
we're voting on
senate bill 251
and we have a motion on the table
to pass
vice chairman pia monty
yes collect votes yes representative
tripp
yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative la silas yes
representative
representative melvin yes
yes representative power yes
representative davis yes
representative jack yes
representative gilman yes
representative perez yes roberto
megapootie
yes up in the van yes
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
ruxin is wrong yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 19 to 0.
thank you
next on our
i'm sorry oh oh without objection i will
place this bill on consent
okay
thank you
uh
our next bill to consider is senate bill
273 a as an alpha
this is relative to broadband
infrastructure
funding
so let me ask
representative mcdonald do you have a
motion to make uh otp
made in second
seeing no discussion let's call the roll
please give me a moment okay take your
time
the committee members i think uh given
the schedule and the clock as i'm
watching it i think we're
on a uh
end the uh
okay
please be patient with catching up on
our paperwork
officer mr chairman thank you okay so
i'm looking for
representative mcdonald to make a motion
you did you already made that motion all
right and uh we had a second from
representative ayer is that correct
yes
okay so uh this is
this is a motion
ought to pass
on
senate bill 273 alpha
let's take a roll
vice chairman pmrt yes black votes yes
representative tripp
yes representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas yes
uh representation
yes melvin yes representative yes
representative power yes
davis
yes representative jack yes
representative gilman yes
represent perez
yes
represent yes
representative fan yes representative
klee
yes
yes representative ryan yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 19 to 0. and without
objection i'll place this in the consent
calendar
thank you uh we're now going to take up
which is relative to adjusted
assessments on taxable property
mr chairman yes
mr chairman i
move ought to pass on senate bill 312.
i think the uh the breadcrumbs i left
out there for lunch coming up soon is
having a having an
effect seeing no uh
no disc no just desired discussion let's
go to a vote
we have a uh proposal on senate bill 312
okay uh vice chairman p.m monty
yes collect votes yes representative
tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representatives los alas yes
representation yes references melvin yes
representative here yes represents power
yes
uh representative davis yes
representative jack yes
representative gilman yes representative
perez
yes
represent mega pooty yes
representative van
yes
representative clee
yes representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 19 to 0. without objection
hmm
uh
we're now going to take up senate bill
317 local
i'll look to uh representative tripp for
a motion mr chairman yeah i move otp
okay
and second
seconded by representative melvin may i
speak to my motion yes you may
all right this is uh
uh
a bill that uh should
a property taxpayer
get an abatement on his tax on their
taxes i wouldn't use the right pronoun
here but uh
that will
lower the rate of uh interest paid on
the abatement from six percent to four
percent and that's all the uh the bill
does
representative melvin you have your mic
okay seeing no further discussion
this is this is a motion on senate bill
317 local
for not to pass we have a motion made
and a second
uh vice chairman pia monty
yes collect votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas yes
representative yes representative melvin
yes
representative here yes representative
power yes
representative davis yes
representative jack yes
representative gilman yes
representative perez yes
representative mangapudi yes
representative vann yes
representative clee yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan yes
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 19-0
without objection we'll put that on the
thank you given the uh
how long i kept you at the last session
we're gonna
break out a little early today so
uh we're gonna end the our executive
session here on senate bill 317 and
we'll pick up
uh on the
on the 27th
9 00 i'll say at 10 a.m
okay
um
you